did george lucas really base owen lars
on an important person in his own life
why exactly does owen hate the jedi so
much
let's dive in to owen lars backstory to
find out
it took years for star wars to get from
george lucas's brain to the big screen
and in that time many of the director's
original ideas underwent some pretty
drastic changes the non-fiction book the
making of star wars the definitive story
behind the original film details how the
scripts evolved over three major drafts
though his part ended up being
relatively small uncle owen was always
intended to be part of the saga in
lucas's rough draft he and his wife beru
are anthropologists stationed on yevin
this might be a nod to the career lucas
may have ended up with if he hadn't
chosen to make movies instead lucas
enrolled in modesto junior college where
he studied anthropology among other
subjects he quickly transferred to film
school at the university of southern
california but his involvement with the
indiana jones franchise makes it clear
that he never really lost interest in
the subject in the second draft owen is
a jedi who along with beru is tasked
with caring for a set of twins biggs and
wendy whose roles in the star wars
universe ended up getting cut down to
background characters during this draft
however lucas introduced the idea of the
lars taking in a young orphaned luke
skywalker by the third draft owen lars
becomes the humble moisture farmer we
know him as today
owen lars may have spent the majority of
his life on tatooine but his story
begins elsewhere in the galaxy owen was
born to cleig lars and his first wife
ika who does not appear in the films
according to the star wars character
encyclopedia updated and expanded the
family of three lived on the core world
planet of atur until she died of an
unspecified cause klig and owen return
home to the family's ancestral moisture
farm on tatooine where the father
teaches his son the trade star wars
canon doesn't specify how old owen is at
this point but these events transpired
before he met his eventual wife peru and
early enough for him to have considered
schmie skywalker stepmother klieg frees
shmee from watto's slavery after which
point she marries him and returns to the
homestead owen learns that he has a
stepbrother anakin
i had a feeling you might show up
someday
when a band of tuscan raiders captured
schmie klieg gathers 30 farmers to
rescue her nearly all are killed in the
effort sensing his mother's distress
anakin and padme arrive on tatooine at
which point the young jedi goes to look
for shmee he finds her in time to share
a final moment with her then slaughters
the tuscan raiders and returns to the
lars moisture farm with her body owen
still a young man has to mourn the loss
of a second mother figure then his own
father who dies of a broken heart
shortly thereafter
owen lars marries varue whiteson a third
generation moisture farmer herself and
the young couple assumes management of
the lars homestead after klig's passing
they expect to start a family and carry
on their family's traditions but sadly
they discover they aren't able to have
children of their own in a short story
from star wars from a certain point of
view we learn that beru and owen
consider using the services of a
fertility droid there are some to be
found on mos eisley but beru decides
against it as mos eisley is too
dangerous a place to order a drink let
alone conceive a baby when you watch a
step
this place can be a little rough
when obi-wan kenobi approaches with the
infant luke skywalker at the end of star
wars revenge of the sith both peru and
owen have reservations baruch suspects
the miracle baby that suddenly appeared
before her is too good to be true and
knows that there is an inherent risk to
taking a child associated with the jedi
owen has a strong distaste for the jedi
stemming from everything that has
happened concerning schmie and anakin
however beru falls in love with the baby
the moment obi-wan puts the swaddled
luke in her arms after his terrible
start in life uru just wants to make
luke happy although owen fears he'll
turn out to be too much like his father
from what we see of owen lars and
obi-wan kenobi they're barely
acquaintances and owen doesn't hold old
ben in high regard in fact he actively
keeps obi-wan away from luke as much as
possible and not without reason in a
series of star wars comics from 2015 we
learn that owen believes his stepmother
to be dead he is angry with the jedi for
letting him fall to the dark side and he
directly blames obi-wan who trained him
in star wars number 15 owen accuses
obi-wan of being the one who got anakin
killed it's implied he suspects that
obi-wan may even be the one who killed
him
though owen accepts responsibility for
the boy because beru wants a family he
refuses to allow obi-wan to train him as
a jedi
owen's distrust of force users goes back
to the depression his stepmother shmee
suffered after the jedi order took her
only son away from her the lars chief
concerns aren't the empire or the jedi
they only want to eke out a happy life
with little luke while avoiding the
corruption and danger posed by the hutts
as much as possible
just because owen tells obi-wan to stay
away doesn't mean he listens
surely obi-wan feels as much
responsibility for anakin's son as owen
and beru did and he also holds out hope
that the skywalker line might still
bring the prophesized balance to the
force and peace to the galaxy obi-wan
watches as luke grows up and shows great
force-wielding potential and even finds
a way to get him spare parts when he
wrecks owen's skyhopper
but of much greater importance he
protects luke owen and beru from threats
they didn't even know existed
in one plot line from the 2015 run of
comics owen admits that he knows obi-wan
is the reason his farm is the only one
never attacked by hutts or tuscan
raiders
owen doesn't permit luke to train under
obi-wan kenobi but he does give him an
education that serves him his whole life
luke's uncle teaches him everything he
knows about hard work discipline
self-defense and mechanical engineering
in one of a series of korean webtoons
published prior to star wars the force
awakens uncle owen teaches a young luke
how to use a blaster rifle and permits
his nephew to learn to pilot his
equipment
though luke repeatedly insists he wants
to get off tatooine and do anything
besides be a moisture farmer owen raises
him to be a self-reliant individual and
prepares him for a difficult future
finally owen's rejection of the jedi and
sith and his ability to carve out a
sense of right and wrong on his own
likely had a profound impact on luke
skywalker after all luke never finishes
his training with yoda choosing to fight
at his friend's side instead a learned
skepticism of the jedi may explain his
mindset when we meet up with him again
in star wars the last jedi after all
luke wouldn't be the man he becomes
without his uncle
since luke skywalker is born into the
empire's reign he wants to be what any
boy would have wanted to be when they
grew up an imperial pilot it seems
ridiculous to imagine in hindsight but
young luke desperately wants to go to
the imperial academy the empire is never
very popular among regular folks across
the galaxy some families would want
their offspring to graduate from the
highest ranking academy branches and
become officers while other parents
would see service as a threat
to be clear luke isn't necessarily
pro-empire when c-3po brings up the
rebel alliance in relation to the
hologram of leia luke is enthusiastic
and curious but until those
circumstances play out luke sees the
academy as his only ticket off of
tatooine and his chance to fly
as a younger man he would often complain
to owen and baru that most of his
friends have already joined but owen
keeps putting him off convincing him to
stay at the farm without uncle owen luke
may well have ended up on the other side
you can go to the academy next year you
must understand i need you
except for a few scenes the star wars
movies are pretty tame
one moment that falls squarely outside
of the realm of family friendly is when
luke returns home to find that his uncle
owen and aunt peru burned to death with
their property still on fire he and
obi-wan realized shortly before that the
empire could trace the droids back to
the lars family through the jawas from
whom they'd been purchased thankfully we
don't witness this brutal scene but we
can't assume that the lars died because
they wouldn't give up information during
a dinner conversation in star wars a new
hope in which luke reveals princess
leia's hidden transmission owen and baru
make it obvious through their sideways
glances at each other that they know
more than they let on however owen also
lets it slip that obi-wan had been
acquainted with his father which is what
piques luke's attention and spurs him
into looking for old ben
that's when the empire visits the lars
homestead still the couple probably
refused to talk about their nephew's
whereabouts the droids or the reclusive
jedi understanding their choice meant
certain depth
in our galaxy practically everyone knows
that darth vader is actually luke's
father but owen lars probably died not
knowing the truth about what became of
his stepbrother anakin skywalker when
obi-wan came to tatooine with anakin's
newborn baby in tow the lars were led to
believe that the jedi knight had
perished but owen does repeatedly lament
that luke has too much of his father in
him
he knew my father
i told you to forget it this would seem
to imply that he is aware of the fact
that anakin switches from jedi to sith
and maybe even that he knows that anakin
is the man under vader's mask
however very few people across the
galaxy are privy to that knowledge a
more realistic scenario is that owen
simply wants luke to stay away from
force users altogether to avoid a
destiny like his father's owen and
baru's deaths became even more
heartbreaking when one realizes that it
is darth vader owens very own
stepbrother who is hunting for the
droids to put an end to the rebel
alliance which is what leads to their
vicious murders
owen lars is a relatively minor
character in the grand scheme of things
but it seems especially considering he
was in the original rough draft that
he's one of outsized importance to
george lucas lucas had a difficult
relationship with his father george
senior who lucas has described as a
domineering ultra right-wing proprietor
of a stationary store as reported in the
atlantic the senior lucas expected his
junior to follow precisely in his
footsteps when his son chose to study
film instead their relationship became
strain lucas readily admits that all of
his films are in a way about fathers and
sons and many are about young men trying
to break free of unideal situations is
there anything i might do to help
well
not unless you can alter time speed up
the harvest or teleport me off this rock
the tension between them is certainly
reflected in uncle owen and in luke's
eagerness to get off of tatooine and
avoid a future spent moisture farming
star wars is about a boy who escapes the
mundane for a great adventure but in the
brief time lucas spends on luke and
uncle owen it's apparent that he's also
working out his feelings about the home
and the family he left behind check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you